this is tomorrow reading from reviewer
stephen petit the play date is a tiny
little handheld filled with wonder and
games you can't find anywhere else with
24 season 1 games delivered in twos
across 12 weeks the playdate has a bunch
of great and inventive experiences out
of the gate understated one bit black
and white visuals and quirky crank
turning gameplay give the playdate a
unique charm but this isn't just a
novelty device the play date feels like
it has lasting power thanks to its
stellar design and open and inviting
approach to game development that will
undoubtedly lead to many more cool and
interesting games after the first season
wraps as you can probably tell already
the play date is very small it measures
in at approximately three by three
inches and is only a third of an inch
thick it has a 2.7 inch display which is
about the same size as a game boy
advanced screen while it doesn't
technically have a backlit screen it's
very reflective which gives it far more
vibrant image than older handhelds
without backlights that said you do need
to play in a fairly well lit area and
tilt the device towards the direction of
the light otherwise objects on screen
are shadowy like an out of focus camera
played as graphical and screen tech
limitations don't stop it from producing
some beautiful and expressive games that
make stellar use of black and white
colors the minimalist design extends to
the controls the play date has a d-pad
two face buttons and of course a crank
the sturdy crank has a metal magnetic
arm and a little pocket on the side of
the device that the handle slots into
allowing it to be stealthily stored away
when not in use you simply lift it up
into place and you're good to go it's a
seamless transition from play mode to
storage mode and vice versa the crank
has a full 360 degree range of motion
and it's utilized in different ways for
each game sometimes it's the main
control method while other times it's
just tied to one small mechanic you
could think of it like the play dates
version of an analog stick due to the
player small size and sometimes rapid
crank turning gameplay the most
comfortable way to hold it for long
sessions is with a claw grip it's easy
to see that it's not an ergonomically
designed handheld but by wrapping your
hands around the small frame it's
actually pretty cozy left-handed users
may have some issues though an
accessibility option lets you invert the
display turning everything backwards but
as you can tell the new location of the
buttons make this control method less
than ideal where the playdate excels is
with the pickup and play mentality it's
seemingly designed to be an always on
handheld with the lock screen showing a
clock when locked it's essentially in
sleep mode and drains very little
battery panic says the play date can
remain on the lock screen for 14 days
between charges whereas actual play time
is roughly 8 hours with a full charge a
prompt on the lock screen informs you
when new games are added as does the
flashing blue light on the lock button
new games are covered in wrapping paper
that makes a thrilling tada sound when
revealed
considering that it has a dock it would
make sense to have a built-in kickstand
unfortunately you'll need to purchase
the play date stereo dock or a small
display stand to prop it up like a clock
playdate has a simple and clean ui all
games are housed as cute little tiles on
the home menu the menu button pauses
your game and pulls up the sidebar that
can be used to instantly return to the
home screen adjust the volume or take a
screenshot the device settings menu
includes network details accessibility
options storage general stuff like that
while play date only has four gigabytes
of storage the games so far take up very
little space even with all 24 season 1
games installed my play date still had
3.7 gigabytes left since we didn't have
12 weeks to experience playdate season 1
we had an accelerated version of
playdate's cool approach to adding new
content two games were digitally
delivered to the play day each day for
12 days this made the play date part of
our daily routine and it was exciting to
have new games to try especially
considering that there are wildly
different experiences to be found on
playdate across a wide variety of genres
ratchetier is a superb top-down
action-adventure reminiscent of classic
zelda games you play as a mechanics
apprentice who has to save the day when
the town is overrun by monsters
[Music]
ratchet has traditional zelda
progression including hidden heart
pieces to find and the tried and true
dungeon setup with gadgets to find to
make use of the crank controls for
example sword spin attacks and
brightening the glow over lantern upper
form by twirling the crank omaze is a
clever puzzle game about maneuvering
through a series of circles it uses 360
degree controls with the crank while
also making use of buttons for
manipulating objects omaze is a great
example of how the crank can be used as
a primary control method to create
effect
[Music]
another game dub 360 is a smart
reimagining of breakout that allows you
to move the paddle on a circular plane
it turns breakout into thrilling chaos
and is filled with unique layouts that
give the classic a new layout strategy
[Music]
but not every game fares as well when
heavily relying on the crank a few games
such as the space game star sled and
hyper meteor require precise and quick
movements that can be frustrating with
the crank and make it feel gimmicky
while the crank is the feature that
makes the play date stand out as a piece
of hardware there are some standout
games that use the crank in very small
ways or not at all for instance demon
quest 85 is an excellent text adventure
revolving around piecing together clues
to summon demons inventory hero is a
resource management game that is fresh
and new thanks to its fast paced loop
that gives you the feeling of an action
game
and questy chess is a wonderful spin on
chess that has grid based levels to work
your way through it retains the
principles and rules of the classic
strategy game while turning it into a
clever tactics game with some seriously
great levels and puzzles to solve
some games are high score chasers that
are fun for quick spurts while others
have a conventional beginning and end
while we haven't completed all of the
games we found that a decent number of
them can be finished in a few hours but
even with more than 50 hours of time
spent with season 1 we've still found
ourselves going back for more and keep
in mind that season 1 is only the
beginning for play date panic designed
the play date to be developer friendly
and community focused anyone can create
a game for playdate and then upload it
to their handheld as well as share or
sell via storefront such as itch panic
has made the entire software development
kit available for free and there's also
a beginner-friendly browser game making
tool called pulp you can make small
games without any prior coding knowledge
and pop's language called pubscript is a
stripped-down coding language with heaps
of easy-to-follow documentation
available already the open nature of
playdate development fuels its future
potential pope isn't the only panic made
software for playdate there's also
mirror which is streaming software for
mac pc and linux the free program allows
you to connect your play date to your
computer to stream your games to sites
such as twitch it also doubles as a way
to play games on larger screens as the
on-screen simulator has a zoom function
that increases the field of view with
mirror you can still use the handheld
for controls or you can use a keyboard
or traditional controllers such as
playstation xbox controllers the analog
stick on your controller becomes the
crank the app has some bugs at the
moment including not recognizing
controller schemes sometimes as well as
larger issues such as screen stuttering
frame skips and input lag while the play
date excels as a compact portable it's
cool that the mirroring option is there
and hopefully improves over time as a
piece of hardware the playdate certainly
punches above its weight it has a
minimalistic design aesthetic that both
charms and gels with what playdate is
all about falling in love with games all
over again by diving into experiences
that feel both brand new and nostalgic
the seasons of games model is a fun way
to keep you coming back for new
surprises and the communal and open
approach to expanding the play date
library gives it enormous potential for
the future
[Music]